انا عماله تنظمي الينا مراسله صباح
العربيه سهى جميل سهى يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
عرفيني على المطعم وفكرته
صباح الخير نادين وسهام انا الان في هذا
المطعم الذي شرع ابوابه منذ سنوات على
اساس فكره العمل الخيري والعمل التطوعي
للمعلومات هذا المطعم لا يضم من عاملين
الا متطوعين يعملون بالمجان يعني الفكره
تاتي من وجبات بسعر التكلفه لاي ضيف او اي
زبون يقوم بشراء وجبه رمزيه واخرى لشخص لا
يعرف من المحتاجين ياتي لتناول هذه الوجبه
المعزوم لا يعرف العزم ولا العازم يعرف
المعزوم بالتالي يدعيني اتعرف اكثر على
هذه الفكره من اجل المحاربه الجوع مع
الاستاذ محمود النابلسي اهلا وسهلا فيك
يعني همم اخبار ثاني ان هذه الفكره تقوم
على العمل التطوعي والعمل الانساني وان
يعني اعداد المحتاجين زادوا بعد فتره
كورونا ماذا تقول عن هذه الفكره مطعم
غزواتي
بالاساس مطعم اجتماعي احنا اكثر همم هو
مطعم همم قائم على المتطوعين والمعزوين
والعازمين هذا هو المثلث الذهبي لمطعم
عزوتي احنا بلاش 2015 هيدخين بالسنه
الثانيه حاليا هلا والمطعم همم قائم على
فكره ال- ال- الكرامه الانسانيه بحيث انه
اي شخص هون بيكون عازم او معزوم اذا كان
عازم بشتري واجبتين واحد له واحد لشخص
ثاني محتاج والشخص الثاني مش بياخذها بشكل
يحفظ كلامكم في الحقيقه اول ما بلشنا كانت
الموضوع انه غريب بال- كيف مطعم شغال في
هذا الطريقه ولكن بعد فتره صف الموضوع انه
سوف ثقافه موجود في المجتمع انه هون
وعزوتي بهذا الموضوع بصراحه الواحد فتره
كورونا همم عدد معزومين زاد عن عدد
العازميين همم
تقصد
فهذا الموضوع
لان احنا ما يكفي عنا اي مصاريف داخليه
غير المواد الاوليه المستخدمها ولكن الحمد
لله الان بعد همم المدارس بتجيء هون
الاهالي بيجيبوا اولادهم فبالتالي نوفر في
العزايم فبالتالي همم المعزومين او
الاشخاص محتاجين لهذا المطعم من خلال
زياره الى مطعم الناس ياتون لتناول
الوجبات اللي فكره المطعم يعني هم ياتون
لي هذا المطعم ليس فقط لاسعار الرمزيه
ولكن لاه
داف فتتكرر الوجوه وتتعدد ايضا وجوه
المحتاجين يعني المعزومين تتكرر وجوههم
اما ال- ال- الذين يعني العازميين تتكرر
وجوههم اما من ياتي لتناول وجبات فهم كثير
من المحتاجين يعني هل انت ترى ان في تعدد
لوجوه المحتاجين في هذا المطعم همم
المحتاجين بيجو في فتره الفطور والغداء
والعشاء فهما اهتمدين بشكل كامل من مطعم
خاصه
بالشوارع اكثر الشباب هل هو بيجيب مصاري
عشان ال- همم يؤمن فيه سكن او داخله ولكن
للاكل ان في مطعم عزوتي موجود على الاقل
هذه الموضوع والصراحه سهب اللي موجود داخل
مطعم ما بتعرف مين هو العازم الا بس يعني
احنا متعودين نعمل اشخاص بغض النظر عن عن
الخلفيات او هو زي ما هو معزوم فبالتالي
ههه
كثير هلا ال عنا عنا كمان في عمليه كبيره
عم تيجي على المطعم خاصه للكبار بالسن
اللي هم عايشين في منطقه وسط البلد هون
وهما يعني ما عندهم ماوى اذا سالتيني فهمم
بيطلعوا احوال تقريبا 70 درجه لواحد عمره
75 سنه يجي ياكل ثلاثه مرات في اليوم فهذا
كمان اكيد عليه ولكن هو بالنهايه بدي اكل
فعزوا تتحول قدر المستطاع توصل لاكبر عدد
ممكن من الاشخاص اللي موجودين داخل
المجتمع الاردني الاردني
يعني من اكثر الجمل التي يعني ما زالت في
الذاكره او على هذا اللوح صلاح همم في همم
مش متعلق مثلا اتزوج واحده انجح بالتوجيهي
بالتعليم وفي ناس يطلبوا منه مثلا باي
مقوله صحتين وعافيه و بصراحه هذا الشكل
نحاول نخلقه انه انت انت نعم مع زمان ولكن
اعزم بحبك وهذاك شخص كمان مستقبلها بحب
اخر شيء بدي احكي لك اياه انه احنا مؤخرا
ااه بعد ما الفكره عالميا صار في مطعم في
المانيا همم موجود حاليا هو عامل عزوتي
هناك زاويه عزوتي بحيث انه الالمان بس
ياكلون ممكن يدعموه مطعم عزوتي
هلا بالصف احنا عم بحاول اشكال استخدامه
انه كمان مطعم هداك بدعم مطعم الموجود في
الاردن ان شاء الله استاذ يعني لهذه
الفكره الانسانيه
هذه الفكره تاتي يعني من رحم الله التفكير
بالغير من الرحم فكره محاربه الجوع يعني
كما قال لهنا صاحب المطعم انه يعني لا لا
نتائج يعني او يعني ارباح
هذا المطعم هو فك فقط يغطون تكلفه ايجار
مكان مطعم عزوتي وتكاليف الطعام والشراب
المنتجات الاوليه
ويعني لا توجد اي ارباح سوى الشعور
الانساني من ان تملا بطن او حاجه انسان
محتاج لوجبه الطعام سهى في من خلال هذه
القصه انا تذكرت شخص خطر على بالي وهذا
الشخص هو انت شخصيا يجب ان تطلق سها جميل
بيتها اسمه عزوتي لانه سهى ايضا يعني
الانسانيه في اسمى معالمها ليس فقط فعل
الخير لمن انسان لانسان فعل الخير من
انسان لحيوان يعني زميلت قوي اكثر من 40
قطه في منزلها تطعمهم تداويهم همم يعني
تلتقطهم من هنا وهناك من شوارع العاصمه
الاردنيه عمان فبالتالي ايضا يعني
رمز الانسانه الجميله والانسان الرائعه
والانسان التي اتشرف دائما بمعرفتها سواء
من خلال المباشر يعني على تقارير العربيه
او من المعرفه المباشره عارفه الانسانيه
تشرفت بسهام ويعني هذا العمل الانساني
الذي اقوم به طبعا بنصائح من قبلكم من قبل
البرنامج صباح العربيه التي اعتز بالعمل
به دائما
صباح العربيه ولقناه العربيه شكرا لك من
عمان مراسله صباح العربيه سوهاج جميل